TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND-
WE'RE NOT THE ONLY HEARING
GOING ON TODAY THERE'S A
HEARING SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
ANOTHER CAPITOL BUILDING THAT'S
A STICKING PLACE THAT- MAY HAVE
CAPTURED OTHER PEOPLES-
ATTENTION BUT- WILL BE
PROCEEDING WITH OUR HEARING
TODAY AND AS- IS- ROUTINE NOW
FOR. OUR RIGHTS HEARINGS I HAVE
A NUMBER OF SAFETY TALKING
POINTS TO BEGIN THE HEARING
WITH. THESE DIRECTIONS ARE
REGARDING PART PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING AND WILL HELP ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE
TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE HERE IN THE ROOM. AND I
DON'T SEE ANYONE BUT PERHAPS
THERE ARE- OF FOLKS LISTENING
AND FOR WHOM THIS WILL BE
RELEVANT- WE ARE OF COURSE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING. BUT EVEN THOUGH
WE ARE IN A RELATIVELY LARGE
VENUE IN THE CAPITAL WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
IN THE MANY SEATS THAT WE HAVE
HERE- AS WELL AS A MINIMAL
CONTAGION OF STAFF AND SO. A
LIMITED NUMBER OF- THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA- ARE ALLOWED IN THE
ROOM AT ANY GIVEN TIME- IN A
MANNER THAT WE CAN ALLOW OUR
CONTINUE TO HAVE SIX FEET OF
SPACING. BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. NOW
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. ALAS THAT- YOU
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE
OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. AT ALL TIMES
INCLUDING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. AND AS WELL LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA AND THE L. A. O. R.
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY- TODAY THERE WILL BE
NO VOTE AND ARE COMMITTEE LET
ME REPEAT WILL BE TAKING NO
VOTES TODAY. WITH RESPECT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL ACCEPT
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. AFTER ALL OF THE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN HEARD BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THAT NUMBER
THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
877-692-8957 AND THERE'S A
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE AND THAT'S.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE. THAT'S.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. YOU MAY ALSO
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO DELIVER PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN DO THAT BY
EMAIL THE EMAIL ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB NUMERAL THREE AT A.
S. M. DOT C. A. DOT G. O. V.
THAT IS B. U. D. G. E. T. S. U.
B. NUMERAL THREE. AT A. S. M.
DOT CA DOT GOV. WE HAVE THREE
ISSUES- TODAY ON OUR AGENDA.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE- BIG ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE PROPOSAL IN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION BUDGET
WILL BE CONSIDERED AT OUR MARCH
SEVENTEENTH HEARING. NOT TODAY.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS BROADBAND
AND OUR FIRST PANEL IS TO
CONSIDER HOW THE STATE CAN HELP
BRIDGE GAPS IN BROADBAND ACCESS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE PANDEMIC
HAS MADE A BROADBAND CONNECTION.
A BECAUSE IT ALWAYS WAS AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE FOR WORK
EDUCATION AND EVEN GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE AND IT'S REALLY I
THINK THE PANDEMIC HAS LAID OUT
IN BROAD RELIEF FOR EVERYONE
JUST HOW IMPORTANT THESE
CONNECTIONS ARE. AND IT'S
EXPOSED SERIOUS GAPS IN SERVICE
PARTICULARLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WHICH ONLY SERVES
TO EXACERBATE MANY OTHER
DISPARITIES LIKE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. EDUCATION AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO NAME JUST A
FEW. SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE PUT FORWARD BILLS TO
EXPAND BROADBAND WHICH IS WHY
IT WAS ALSO INCLUDED AS A
PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET
BLUEPRINT THAT THE ASSEMBLY
RELEASED IN DECEMBER. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN WORKING
ON A BROADBAND FOR ALL
INITIATIVE. BUT THE BUDGET THUS
FAR DOES NOT INCLUDE A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA SO TODAY
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
OPTIONS THAT THE STATE COULD
EXPLORE. TO EXPLORE EXPAND
BROADBAND ACCESS. AND TO LOOK
AT ANY OF THESE OPTIONS AND SEE
IF THEY'RE NIMBLE ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS THE URGENT NEEDS THAT
MANY CALIFORNIANS. IN OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
OUR URBAN AREAS IN OUR RURAL
AREAS THERE ARE SO MANY PLACES
WHERE THIS NEED IS DIRE AND
THAT- WE'VE BECOME. EVEN MORE
AWARE OF DO THE PANDEMIC. SO
WITH NO FURTHER ADO- WE HAVE-
OUR PANEL TODAY IN THE
FOLLOWING- ON THIS ISSUE IN THE
FOLLOWING INDIVIDUALS. WILL
PARTICIPATE VIRTUALLY IN THE
DISCUSSION OF THIS ISSUE WHAT
I'LL DO IS INTRODUCE THE PANEL
THAT WILL TAKE ROLE BECAUSE I
SEE WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE. OF
OUR PANEL WILL CONSIST OF
COMMISSIONER MARTHA GOOS MON A
SEVENTH. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. ROB OSBORNE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ROSS BROWN OF THE L.
A. O. AND- DAMIEN MEMNOCH AYMAN
BANNED AND MARK MONROE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHY
DON'T WE TAKE ROLE AND THEN-
WILL ASK THE PANEL TO BEGIN.
HELLO HERE SENATE HERE FRIEDMAN
MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS. YOUR
HAVE FUN GREAT- I'M NOT SEEING
ANYBODY ON THE SCREEN THE TALK
TALKING. FIFTY GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN RODRIGUEZ. GOOD
MORNING THERE YOU ARE WELCOME.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
WOMAN THANK YOU FOR HAVING A
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
MARTHA BECAUSE MINE NOT SERVICE
I AM ONE OF THE COMMISSIONERS
AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. I REALLY
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY
AND DISCUSS SOME OF THE KEY
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN. OUR
AS YOU MENTIONED NOT JUST
RECENTLY BUT REALLY ACUTELY-
THAT RIDLEY ARE- PROHIBITING US
FROM ADVANCING ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY. AND QUALITY
BROADBAND SERVICE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU MENTIONED
THE- DID INCLUDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THESE KEY BARRIERS AND
CHALLENGES. AND REALLY OUTLINED
SOME OF THE STRATEGIES NEEDED
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
TO ACCOMPLISH BY GETTING OUT
THESE ISSUES. PROTECTING
CONSUMERS ATTAINING AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND SERVICE ARE SOME OF
THE KEYS BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OBVIOUSLY A
MAJOR AREA. AND REFORMING OUR
STATE UNIVERSAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SUPPORTING OUR LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND I'M GONNA GET
INTO A COUPLE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AT A BROAD
LEVEL OF HOW WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS. I
WANT TO START WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND AND- RECOGNIZE
ALL THAT IS HAPPENING TODAY TO
TRY TO GET OUT THIS ISSUE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY. STILL
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. WHO MAY HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME FORM OF
INFRASTRUCTURE COULD NOT AFFORD
IT AT THE LEVEL THAT THEY NEED
IT. ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
TODAY HAVE AN ACCESS ISSUE. ONE
POINT SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
DO SUBSCRIBE TO THE STATE'S LOW
INCOME SUBSIDY PROGRAM KNOWN AS
THE CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM
THAT I KNOW YOU WILL BE
DISCUSSING FURTHER TODAY. THIS
PROGRAM DOES NOT YET PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE BROADBAND NEEDS FOR
TELEWORK TELEHEALTH AND
DISTANCE LEARNING AND I'LL
TOUCH ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
REFORM IN THAT PROGRAM AND
ENHANCING IT LATER ON. IN
ADDITION THE STATE'S MAJOR ISPS
AT&T FRONTIER COMCAST **** AND
CHARTER- ACCOUNT 495% OF THE
STATE'S BROADBAND CONNECTIONS.
EACH OFFER HELLO REDUCE COSTS
PLAN HOWEVER CUMULATIVELY ALL
OF THEM ONLY OFFER THOSE PLANS
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SUBSCRIBERS SO THE GAP IS STILL
HUGE. EVERY DAY THESE COMPANIES
CONTINUE TO MAKE GREATER
COMMITMENTS AND I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. THESE COMMITMENTS ARE
UNENFORCEABLE. AND THEY
CURRENTLY ARE NOT MEETING NEEDS
ESPECIALLY OF ALL THE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. IN
NOVEMBER I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONGRESSIONAL
ACTION INCLUDED AN EMERGENCY
BROADBAND BENEFIT THAT WOULD
INCREASE AT THAT WOULD PROVIDE
A SUBSIDY OF FIFTY DOLLARS A
MONTH. BUT IT'S ONLY FOR A FEW
MONTHS AT ALL YOU WANT TO
RECOGNIZE IT DOES PROVIDE
DOUBLE WHAT THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY DOES FOR THE
VOICE AND VOICE SERVICES. IT'S
ONLY A ONE TIME FUNDING PROGRAM.
SO THERE'S POTENTIAL THERE BUT
IT IS. JUST A SOMEWHAT OF A
PILOT PROGRAM. IN ADDITION-
CALIFORNIA DID RECEIVE SOME OF
THE FEDERAL MONEY SIX HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE MILLION OF THE
FC'S RULES DIGITAL OPPORTUNITY
FUN. BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
RECEIVED A HIGH AMOUNT OF LOW
QUALITY PROJECTS THAT WILL
LIKELY NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE THAT WE NEED NOW WE
ARE WORKING ON MAKING THOSE-
PROPOSALS AS BEST AS THEY CAN.
BUT NOT WHAT WE WANTED TO SEE.
SO WHY ARE THESE MEASURES
WORKING. THE KEY HERE TO REALLY
TAKE HOME IS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT ENFORCEABLE. UNLIKE OTHER
SERVICES WATER ELECTRICITY AND
GAS UTILITY SERVICES BROADBAND
SERVICE IS NOT REGULATED AS IN
A SPECIAL SERVICE THAT IT IS.
EITHER BY US AT THE STATE LEVEL
NOR AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THE
MANNER IN WHICH HE READILY
BROADBAND IS THE FOUNDATIONAL
CHANGE THAT WE NEED IN ORDER TO
ATTAIN UNIVERSAL SERVICE
RELIABLE SERVICE AND AFFORDABLE
SERVICE. HISTORICALLY THE STATE
DESIGNATED TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS AS A SERVICE WITH THE
SERVICE TERRITORY AND WE USED
AND WE MANDATED THAT PROVIDERS
SERVE EVERY HOUSEHOLD IN THEIR
SERVICE TERRITORY THIS IS FOR
THE VOICE SERVICE. THAT
REQUIREMENT IS CALLED THE
KERRIER OF LAST RESORT THAT'S
HOW WE WERE ABLE TO MANDATE
RELIABLE TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
ACCESS TO NINE ONE ONE FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIAN FOR THE LAST
CENTURY. THE STATE COUPLE THOSE
REQUIRED FOR THOSE REQUIREMENTS
ON THE CARRIERS WITH A SUBSIDY
TO OFFSET THE COST TO EVERYONE.
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE HIGH COST
AREAS IN RURAL SPARSELY
POPULATED DIFFICULT TO SERVE
AREAS. THESE PROGRAMS STILL
EXIST TODAY AND ARE CALLED THE
HIGH COST FUND PROGRAMS THERE'S
A NEED TO BE. HOWEVER THE V.
FINE WHICH IS THE PRIMARY ONE
ONLY SUBSIDIZES VOICE SERVICE
AND OF COURSE I WILL TALK ABOUT
HOW THAT FUND NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED. WE ALSO SUBSIDIZE THE
CARRIERS FOR PROVIDING A
DISCOUNT TO LOW INCOME BOYS
SERVICES OUT AS WE KNOW THROUGH
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM AND THAT
IS AGAIN A PROGRAM THAT NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED FOR BROADBAND.
THIS POLICY REGION CURRENTLY
DOESN'T EXIST FOR BROADBAND
INSTEAD WE HAVE AN UNREGULATED
COMMUNICATIONS MARKET. WE NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER TO ESTABLISH
THESE BASIC REQUIREMENTS ON
ISPS THAT THEY SERVE EVERYONE
AND THAT THEY PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE SERVICE TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE. WE SHOULD ALSO
CONCURRENTLY ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
ARE COSTS NEED TO BE OFFSET AND
UPDATE OUR HIGH COST FUND IN
OUR LIFELINE PROGRAM TO ASSIST
IN COVERING THOSE COSTS. WHEN I
TALK ABOUT A PARTICULAR ACT
THAT'S RELEVANT FOR MAKING
THESE CHANGES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VIDEO COMMUNICATIONS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX IT'S ALSO KNOWN AS
DIFFICULT. IT WAS ONE OF THE
KEY ACTS THAT DEREGULATED THE
COMMUNICATIONS MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA. HIGHER TO DISCUSS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS USE THEIR
LICENSING AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
THAT CARRIERS WERE PROVIDING
QUALITY SERVICE AFFORDABLE
OFFERINGS AND THAT THESE
COMPANIES WERE SERVING THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. DIFFICULT WAS
REPLACED I REPLACED THIS LOCAL
CONSTRUCT WITH A STATEWIDE
STRUCTURE WHERE NOW THE PC
PROVIDES A FRANCHISE LICENSE
AND WE HAVE VERY LITTLE
OVERSIGHT. THE NETWORK BUILD
OUT AND LOW INCOME REQUIREMENTS
FROM THE ACT HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN TEN YEARS. THERE'S
BEEN RECENT STUDIES BY U. S. C.
GREEN LINING NDA AND OTHERS
INCLUDING SOME OF OUR OWN THAT
HAVE SHOWN THAT THIS HAS
RESULTED IN REDLINING IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THE ACT MAKES- OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE ISSUES
IMPOSSIBLE IT NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED TO PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE. OF MEASURES FOR
SERVICE AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS. TODAY THERE HAS
BEEN NO ENFORCEMENT ACTION
UNDER THE ACT. I CAN TELL YOU
PERSONALLY EVERY WEEK I
RECEIVED NUMEROUS CALLS FROM
COMMUNITIES COUNCILMEMBERS
SUPERVISORS. COOPER ATTENDANCES
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE BEEN DOING
INCREDIBLE WORK. THERE'S
COMMUNITIES LIKE ON THE WEST
SIDE OF FRESNO COMMUNICABLE
VIOLA FOR THEIR SERVICE ON ONE
SIDE HISTORY BUT NOT THE OTHER
WE ALL HEARD OF THE YOUNG WOMEN
IN SALINAS THE YOUNG CHILDREN
IN SALINAS THAT LACKED ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE SERVICE. JUST
YESTERDAY I RECEIVED A CALL A
EMAIL FROM A MOBILE HOME PARK
IN GILROY. WHOSE CABLE COMPANY
WAS STARTING TO DISCONNECT
THEM. NOT BECAUSE OF LACK OF
PAYMENT BUT BECAUSE THEY NO
LONGER WERE PAYING FOR THE
VIDEO SERVICE. ALL OF THESE
ISSUES THEY'RE ALL UNIQUE THEY
ALL HAVE THE ABILITY TO. OF BE
REMEDIED WITH SOME REGULATORY
CONSTRUCT. AND BY THE WAY I
WOULD SAY MOST NOT ALL THAT I
WOULD SAY- YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH A LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY HAVE TO DO WITH THE LACK
OF REGULATION. SO THE ACT NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED TO ENSURE THAT
THE LARGEST INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE PROVIDING
INTERNET SERVICES TO ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS IN COMMUNITIES.
AND AFFORDABLE PLANS TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. BY THE WAY
WE'RE NOT THE ONLY ONE LOOKING
OUT OUR CONSTRUCTS THE NEW YORK
NEW YORK'S GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
CUOMO JUST ANNOUNCED THAT HE
WILL PROPOSE- A PERSON NATION
REQUIREMENT THROUGH LEGISLATION
REQUIRING ISPS TO OFFER AN
AFFORDABLE FIFTEEN DOLLAR MONTH
PLAN FOR HIGH SPEED INTERNET TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. OKAY SO
I THINK YOU GOT THE MESSAGE ON
THE NEED FOR REGULATION HERE-
THE OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE TO THE PUZZLE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE NEED TO
CONSIDER OUR INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS SOMETHING
THAT IS CONTINUOUS AND WILL BE
LIKE ANY OTHER OUR SYSTEM OF
UTILITY SERVICE THAT NEEDS
CONSTANT REINVESTMENT. M.
BROADBAND IS NO DIFFERENT.
HERE'S SOME OF THE NUMBERS FOR
THE LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE ARE STILL SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE NOT
CONNECTED CALIFORNIA AND THAT
IS THE LARGEST POPULATION THAN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
UNFORTUNATELY. 33% A RURAL
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE HAVE NO
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND. TRIBAL
LANDS ARE VERY DEEPLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WERE 24% OF THEIR HOMES ARE
WITHOUT ACCESS. THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND CSF IS
THE MOST CRITICAL STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUND AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXTENDING THAT PROGRAM IN
MAKING IT EVEN MORE SUCCESSFUL.
SINCE IT A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WHEN IT BEGAN THE PROGRAM HAS
FUNDED SEVENTY SEVEN PROJECTS
WHICH HAVE PROVIDED SERVICE TO
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. TODAY WE ARE IN A
CURRENT ROUND OF FUNDING ANY IS
OVER SUBSCRIBED WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECT REQUESTS AND WE HAVE A
TO APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION REMAINING. WE'VE
CONDUCTED AN INITIAL COST
ASSESSMENT THAT DIRECTOR
OSBORNE COULD GET INTO MUCH
MORE DETAIL ON IT WHAT IF
THERE'S INTERESTS. BUT THE COST
RANGES FOR SERVING THE STATE
ARE BETWEEN SIX TO SEVEN
BILLION AND IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
CURRENT CASF INFRASTRUCTURE
FUND DOES NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES FOR THAT. AND AGAIN
WE WANT TO SEE THIS AS THE
INJECTION OF FUNDING THAT IS
NEEDED TODAY BUT IT WILL BE A
CONTINUOUS NEED FOR
REINVESTMENT. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT SOME OF THE EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS IN THE STAFF OUR OUR
REPORT. AS YOU CONTINUE TO
EXAMINE THE NEED FOR EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM WE REALLY DO WANT
TO REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE FOR
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF TRIBAL
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY HAVE
SUCH A PIVOTAL ROLE TO PLAY IN
CLOSING THIS DIVIDE. THERE IS A
NEED FOR GREATER CAPACITY
FUNDING FOR THOSE LOW- IN AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROGRAM'S HISTORY IS CHRONIC
CHRONICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS I
CAN'T FORGET TO MENTION
COMMUNITIES LIKE LOST HILLS.
NEVER GET AN APPLICATION
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT REALLY A
MARKET INCENTIVE FOR THEM T
GET SERVICE OF THE CARRIERS
DON'T COME IN WITH APPLICATIONS
WE NEED THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
KNOW THESE AREAS ARE
CHRONICALLY UNDERSERVED TO HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO FINALLY APPLY.
TO SERVE FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE ALSO NEED TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS FOR EXPEDITING THESE-
BUILDS THIS CONSTRUCTION
BUILDS. BY ELIMINATING A
PRACTICES THAT HAVEN'T HAPPENED
IN PREVIOUS YEARS LIKE CARVE
OUTS TO INCUMBENTS OR PROVIDING
COMMENTS A RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL. THIS HASN'T WORKED IN
THE LAST REAUTHORIZATION OF THE
CASF PROGRAM THERE WAS BRITNEY
SENSUALLY A CARVE OUT FOR
FRONTIER NAY T. AND T. FOR TWO
YEARS. AND EIGHTEEN T. NEVER
APPLIED FOR ONE DOLLAR SO.
AREAS LIKE JUST NORTH OF
PARADISE NEVER WE'RE WAITING
FOR TWO YEARS ASKING AT&T MONTH.
AFTER MONTH ARE YOU GONNA
SERVICE OR NOT. AND THEY DO IT.
SO PLEASE DON'T THAT AGAIN HI
TO PROVIDE THAT SORT OF
CONSTRUCT. AND FINALLY CONSIDER
THAT THESE ARE THESE FUNDS AS I
MENTIONED WILL BE NEEDED
CONTINUOUSLY. I ALSO WANT TO
BRING- THE FINAL ISSUE THAT WAS
REALLY OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S- EIGHT PAGES WHICH
IS THE IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND REALLY TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE EXCITING
MODELS THAT ARE OCCURRING BOTH
IN OUR STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION. BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
BROADBAND IS A LOCAL ISSUE
TRIBAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE THE ABILITY AND TOOLS TO
BUILD BY KNOWING THE NEEDS BUT
ALSO BY EXPEDITING PERMITTING
AND USING THEIR PLANNING
AUTHORITIES AND OTHER
INCENTIVES THAT THEY CAN BUNDLE
TOGETHER AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IDEALLY THEY COULD ALSO BUILD
THEIR OWN FOUNDATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT COULD BE
USED TO BRING IN EVEN MORE
COMPETITION. AS WE KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE MORE DRIVEN TO
SEE SUCCESS IN THEIR ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY SERVICE AND THEY SEE
THAT DIRECT CONNECTION WITH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
SOME. EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE
KNOW OF TODAY CORE FUNCTIONS
EDUCATION HEALTH CARE. THERE'S
MANY EXAMPLES BUT LET ME TELL
YOU ABOUT A FEW IN UTAH THERE'S
A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY CALLED
UTAH TELECOMMUNICATIONS OPEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AGENCY. OR
UTOPIA. THEY BUILT AND THEN
THERE CONTINUOUSLY BUILDING AN
OPEN ACCESS FIBRE NETWORK THAT
PROVIDE SERVICE TO ELEVEN
CITIES. AND THEY DO SO WITH
ACTUALLY A BONDING MECHANISM
THAT PROVIDES THAT IS BASED ON
VERY LITTLE A PUBLIC FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THEY'RE ABLE TO USE
THEIR REVENUE BASE. BUT THEIR
MODEL ESSENTIALLY IS THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS FUNDED THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN THE
ALLOW CARRIERS TO COMPETE ON
TOP OF IT FOR CUSTOMERS
ACCOUNTS. MANY CITIES HAVE ALSO
DEVELOP MASTER PLANS TO
STREAMLINE THE PERMITTING OF
FIVE G. SMALL CELLS AND FIBER
OPTIC CABLES. THIS ENABLES
SMART CITY SOLUTIONS SMART
BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES SMART
STREETLIGHTS INTELLIGENT
TRAFFIC SIGNAL SYSTEMS SMALL
CELLS AND PUBLIC WIFI. ALL OF
THESE ARE MORE REASONS TO BUILD
THE CAPACITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND FINALLY BUT NOT
JUST LAST YEAR I WAS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A VIRTUAL RIBBON
CUTTING OF THE SOUTH BAY CITIES
CAPS COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
FIBER NETWORK THE BAY BUILT ON
THEY USED A COUPLE OF THE USED
RACE COMMUNICATIONS IN AMERICAN
DARK FIBER BUT- THEY COMPLETED
A REGIONAL MUNICIPAL BROADBAND
NETWORK THAT SERVES UP FOR
FIFTEEN OF THE CITIES. IN THE
LOS ANGELES SOUTH BAY REGION
AND THEY HAVE OBVIOUSLY A
VISION TO DO MORE WITH. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
AND JUST IN SOME I WANT TO SAY
THAT IT'S REALLY A CRITICAL
TIME NOW FOR US TO TAX AND WE
CAN ACTUALLY ACHIEVE SOME OF
THESE GOALS I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S OUTLINED REALLY HITS
ON THE TOP. TOP PRIORITIES THAT
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BY
ESTABLISHING REQUIREMENTS TO
SERVE. REQUIREMENTS TO OFFER
AFFORDABLE PLANS. WE NEED TO
REFORM OUR LIFELINE AND HIGH
COST PROGRAMS TO OFFSET THE
COST OF PROVIDING THESE
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND SERVICES.
WE NEED TO EXTEND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. AND WE
NEED TO BUILD THE CAPACITY OF
TRIBAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS OUR
DIRECTOR DIRECTOR ROB OSBORNE.
WELL I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE VERY- DETAILED- A SUMMARY
OF THE- THE GREAT NEED THAT
EXISTS IN THE IN THE STATE TO
HAVE BOTH ON. BOTH FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- I THINK IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT- THESE ARE
ALL AREAS THAT- WE NEED TO BE
EXPLORING THAT- WHY DON'T DRIVE
RATHER THAN GET INTO QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW I THINK. LET'S HEAR
THE REST OF THE REPORTS AND
FLUORIDE. SO WE'LL HEAR FROM-
MR OSBORNE NEXT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I DIDN'T COME
WITH ANY PREPARED STATEMENT SO
I'M HAPPY TO YIELD MY TIME.
OKAY- MISTER BROWN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE TO THE L. A. I'LL
HAVE A REPORT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROSS BROWN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE A LOT TO
ADD AT THIS POINT OTHER THAN
TO. REITERATE WHAT THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR DOESN'T
HAPPEN A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL ON%
THIS RIGHT NOW WE UNDERSTAND
THE- IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOUR- COMMITTEE AND STAFF GOING
FORWARD AS YOU EXPLORE THIS
ISSUE FORWARD AND NOT GOING
FORWARD AND- PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHERE POSSIBLE. SO I
HAVE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS SO.
THANK YOU- AND- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YEAH I AM AN ALBUM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
MINISTRATIONS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
BROADBAND- WITH OUTLANDER
PRINCIPLES IN EIGHT PAGES- AND
QUARTIER CONVERSATIONS COME.
WELL OKAY THANK YOU SO LET ME-
I BEGIN WITH YOU AND ASK YOU-
THE FIRST QUESTION- WE
APPRECIATE HAVING THE- THE
EIGHT PAGE OUTLINE. OF BUT THAT
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFICITY WITH RESPECT TO
ACTUAL PROPOSALS AND I. HEAR
THAT- WE CAN ANTICIPATE THAT
THAT WILL BE PROVIDED TO US CAN
YOU CONFIRM THAT AND CAN YOU
CONFIRM THAT IT WILL BE BROUGHT
TO US. OF IN TIME FOR US TO
GIVE IT THE- NECESSARY REVIEW
THAT- COMMITTEE STAFF FIVE-
WILL WANT TO PROVIDE AN FOR A
PUBLIC CONSIDERATION AT HEARING.
I'M ON THE EIGHT PAGES I
BELIEVE IT DOES PROVIDE SOME
LEVEL OF DETAIL- WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK- TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TERMS OF THE
SPECIFICITY OF IT YOUR REQUEST-
WAIT. IT WOULD JUST BE GOING
DOWN THROUGH EIGHT PAGES AND
SHOWING KIND OF WHAT EACH
ELEMENT REPRESENTS TERMS AND
INITIATIONS PROPOSAL AND HAPPY
TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOUR STUFF.
MISTER GOODMAN A SERVICE. I
JUST PROVIDED US WITH A FAIRLY
DETAILED SUMMARY OF VARIOUS
AREAS- OF- WHERE- SHE THINKS
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE. ARE
THESE THE THINGS THAT ARE UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- YES THE-
COMMISSIONER IS REPRESENTING-
THE INTENTIONS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN UP OF
FINALLY. THE- OF WEEK WE CAN
FIND FOR THE LONG TERM BUT I
THINK OTHERS A GREAT INTEREST
IN GETTING MOVING ON THIS
ISSUE- QUICKLY SO ARE THERE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS THAT CAN
BE. OF FUNDED IN THE NEAR TERM
AS OPPOSED TO- SOME OF THE
OTHER CHANGES LIKE REGULATORY
CHANGES IT'LL PROBABLY TAKE
SOME TIME. I BELIEVE SO- AGAIN
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT'S RISED
IN THE GENDER IS THE ISSUE
REVENUE COLLECTION IN THESE
PROGRAMS. AB YOU GUYS REYES-
THE IDEA OF BRINGING REPORT
GENERAL FUND THAT'S A NEW
PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
I'M HAPPY TO BRING BACK TO THE
MINISTRATION AND CONSULT WITH
THAT I BELIEVE THERE ARE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE READY TO GET
OUT THE DOOR. THANK YOU- LET ME
ASK MY COLLEAGUES SO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. THE THREE OF US-
MS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT- IF THE STATE WERE TO USE
SOME OF ITS CASH ON HAND TO
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND- WHAT METRICS WITH
THE . YOU SEE USED TO ENSURE
THAT DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WERE
COMPETITIVE. MISTER CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO TAKE SOME. OF
THE GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IRONICALLY I'M I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISSED PART OF THE
QUESTION BUT MY INTERNET WAS
COMING IN AND OUT- WE
UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU KNOW-
UNLIMITED WE HAVE A PROCESS
WHERE WE DO TAKE AND- ALL OF
THE CRITERIA THAT THE
LEGISLATION HAS- DIRECTED US
AND WE ABSOLUTELY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL A SCORING FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LOW INCOME
OF COURSE THE THRESHOLD
ELIGIBILITY IS THAT THEY ARE
NOT UNDER UNSERVED AREAS. AND I
CAN I CANSAY JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE SO LAST- OUR LAST ROUND
OF- GRANT RECIPIENTS WERE A SET
OF LOW INCOME PRIMARILY LOW
INCOME MOBILE HOME PARKS IN THE
GREATER A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREA MANY OF THESE ARE PROJECTS
THAT ARE KIND OF DONATED IT.
THE LITTLE DOUGHNUTS OUTSIDE OF
THE SERVICE AREAS OF MANY OF
THE I. S. P.'S- SO ABSOLUTELY A
PRIORITY I AND I REITERATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THE
CAPACITY BUILDING AS WELL
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW SOME SOME OF
THESE AREAS NEED TO BE
DEVELOPED INTO APPLICATIONS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO TRIBES
M. AND WE CERTAINLY LIKE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION OF
EXPLORING EXPANDING. THAT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU WITH FRIEDMAN. YEAH
THANKS I WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL
THANK ARM THE COMMISSIONER FOR
I'M OUTLINING NOT JUST AT THE
NEED FOR FUNDING BUT THE NEED
FOR FAR GREATER REGULATION TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDS ARE GETTING
TO THE PLACES WHERE THEY WERE
INTENDED TO AND ALSO TO OUTLINE
FOR US THE- I'D SAY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF SOME OF THE-
THE STIPULATIONS ON THE LAST
PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF STOPPING
COMPETITION- PREVENTING SOME OF
THE UTILITIES FROM. GIVING THEM
TOO MUCH OF AN OUT TO NOT SPEND
MONEY WHERE MONEY NEEDS TO BE
SPENT AND ALSO THE- OF SOME
COMMUNITIES BEING UNABLE TO
APPLY FOR MONEY THAT'S ON THE
TABLE. SO I'M GLAD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING WITH
YOU IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY- TO APPROVE A
LOT OF THOSE BARRIERS OUT TO
CREATE THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
MONEY THAT TO PUT INTO THE
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY SPENT WHERE
WE INTENDED. TO I AM NEW TO
THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE BUT IT'S MY
ASSUMPTION. BUT A LOT OF THOSE
REGULATORY. GUARDRAILS ARE NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT HERE BUT I DO HOPE
THAT THAT MESSAGE GETS TO THE
AUTHORS OF THE VARIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT'S GOING TO BE
INTRODUCED IN CERTAIN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PRIORITISES YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TO SHARE
THEM WITH US. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT TO- BEFORE
WE LEAVE THIS ISSUE- I HAVE A-
A COMMENT AND A QUESTION ON A-
ISSUE THAT'S NOT BEFORE US
TODAY BUT- I WANTED TO RAISE
AND I KNOW THAT- STAFF WILL NOT
BE HERE- WHO WERE. ABLE TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION SO I HOPE
THAT TO. YOU'LL TAKE IT UNDER
ADVISEMENT AND TO RETURN-
EITHER TO HEARING OR- SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE.
CERTAIN PROTOCOLS AND TIME
LINES THAT WE NEED TO HEAR TO.
IN OUR REGULATORY PROCESS AND
THAT. ENERGY PROCEEDINGS IN
PARTICULAR CAN BE. VERY
COMPLICATED. WITHOUT QUESTION
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT RUSH
THROUGH THESE PROCEEDINGS. NOT
ONLY FOR TRANSPARENCY PURPOSES
BUT ALSO SO THAT WE IDENTIFY
AND RESOLVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. HOWEVER A NUMBER
OF STAKEHOLDERS- IN THE-
ENERGY- AREA HAVE REACHED OUT
TO ME ABOUT CONCERNS THAT MANY
PROCEEDINGS ARE NOT GETTING
COMPLETED IN WHAT THEY CONSIDER
A TIMELY MANNER. AND ALL THESE
DELAYS ARE IMPACTING OUR
ABILITY TO ADDRESS RELIABILITY
AND MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
THERE WAS ALSO A RECENT ARTICLE
IN THE LA TIMES THAT SUPPORTS.
THIS NOTION AS WELL AS A LETTER
THAT I AM IN POSSESSION OF THAT
WAS RECENTLY SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR BY A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT SHARES THIS
SAME CONCERN SO MY QUESTION IS
BASED ON WHAT I'M HEARING. DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
COMPLETING PROCEEDINGS IN A
TIMELY MANNER- AND IF NOT THEN
WHAT ARE THE FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS LACK OF
PROGRESS ON PROCEEDINGS AND HOW
CAN WE FIX THOSE ISSUES SO THE
RULES CAN BE ADOPTED QUICKER IN
A TIMELY FASHION TO ALLOW
NECESSARY WORK TO GET DONE.
WHETHER IT'S BUILDING OUT
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROMOTING INVESTMENT AND DEMAND
RESPONSE STORAGE OR MICRO GRIDS
OR AFFORDABLY PROCURING
RESOURCES TO MEET RELIABILITY
AND OTHER COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENT. I KNOW A AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THESE
HEARINGS THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE STAFF HERE
TODAY TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS. SO I'M ASKING OUR
STAFF TO SEND MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS TO YOU REGARDING
THESE CONCERNS AND- WILL AWAIT
YOUR RESPONSE AND AFTER YOUR
RESPONSE WE MAY WANT TO REVISIT
THIS ISSUE IN A FUTURE HARRIS.
OF THANK YOU FOR PATIENTLY
LISTENING- TO THAT QUESTION AND
I APPRECIATE- YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE OF THE
QUESTION. HUNTER A- WITH THAT
WILL MOVE ON TO- UNLESS A- YOU
WANT TO ADD SOMETHING GOTTA-
MISS THIS IS A GOOD MAN A
SERVICE. OF FOR A HEARTY CAL
WEATHERMAN AND IN THIS SETTING
WHETHER WHETHER YOU'RE WAITING
TO SAY SOMETHING OR YOU'RE JUST
PAYING. RAPT ATTENTION WHEN I'M
SURE YOU ARE THE AUTHOR OF. NO
I JUST I APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION AND WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOU ON ON YOUR INVITATION
TO WHO-TO ADDRESS ANY ISSUES
THAT CAN HELP US BE MORE
EXPEDITIOUS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT
AND CHAIRMAN IF I COULD JUST
JUST MAKE ONE COLLEAGUES AS AS
AS WE AND THIS AND THAT IS.
THAT IF IT'S IF IT'S NOT.
OBVIOUS TO MOST PEOPLE NOW THAT
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND IS TRULY
AN ESSENTIAL UTILITY JUST
IMAGINE TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS
FROM NOW- YOU KNOW LITERALLY
YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING IT MAY
BE VERY DIFFICULT EVEN MAINTAIN
YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING WITHOUT
IT AND SO. I THINK WE HAVE TO
PROACTIVELY LOOK AT IT THAT WAY
AND MAKE SURE WE TREATED JUST
LIKE HAVING ELECTRICITY AND
WATER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME BYE I WAS-
LAUGHING TO MYSELF DURING THE
PRESENTATION- WHEN NAVAS SAID A
GOOD MINISTER OF US WAS
REFERRING TO- THE- EXISTING.
LAWS WERE TRULY FACILITATE
VOICE COMMUNICATION AND I
THOUGHT HOW MANY PEOPLE REALLY
USE VOICE YOU KNOW HOW HOW HOW
MANY TELEPHONE CALLS WE MAKE
TODAY AS OPPOSED TO EVERY OTHER
MEANS OF COMMUNICATION- THAT
EXISTS IN THE OF MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT USES THAT- WE PUT OUR
DEVICES TO. AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE THE ISSUE IS TODAY- AND-
THERE'S BEEN A DRAMATIC SHIFT
AND- AND THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
ALLOWS FOR SO MUCH MORE THAN-
AT ONE TIME EXISTED. OUR SECOND
ISSUE IS THE- ASSEMBLY
MISCELLANEOUS- THREE
MISCELLANEOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS
THAT ARE. SUMMARIZED HERE AND
THE- OF FOLLOWING GO
INDIVIDUALS WILL PARTICIPATE IN
THE DISCUSSION OF THIS ISSUE WE
HAVE JONATHAN BLACK ROOTS WITH
THE- CPC. AS WELL AS GEN
CALIPHATE OF AND THE- THE L. A.
O. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
WELL. MR UGH UGH LACQUERED
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO. YES
GOOD MORNING TERBOVEN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JONATHAN MARKETS AND
I'M A PROGRAM MANAGER AND THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION'S COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION. STAFF HAS ASKED US TO
SKIP PRESENTATIONS SO AS TO
MAKE THE MOST USED TO RETIRE BY
ALLOWING FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT THE LIFELINE INDOOR THE
PROGRAM CLAIMS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS PCPS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BROWN YOU HAVE A
REPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ROSS BROWN I KNOW WE HAVE WE
HAVE REVIEWED THE BCPS WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE ONES
THAT ARE ON THE AGENDA- WE
WOULD JUST NOTE ONE THING ON
THE LIFELINE ESTIMATES WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THOSE
ESTIMATES BUT THOSE ARE UPDATED
AND MAY AS WELL AND SO. WHEN
THOSE UPDATED ESTIMATES ARE
AVAILABLE WILL REVIEW THEM AND
PROVIDE OUR COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THAT NOTHING THAT
THANK YOU I'M ALSO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DECLINE IN
LIFELINE PARTICIPATION THAT IS
ANTICIPATED LATER THIS YEAR
WHAT STEPS TO THE PC IS THE PC
ANTICIPATING TAKING TO- TRY TO
INCREASE OUTREACH TO VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU CHAIR
THIS IS JONATHAN MARKETS UP WE
ARE TAKING SEVERAL STEPS UP
FIRST WERE MAKING OUR RENEWAL
PROCESS AS EASY AS POSSIBLE SO
WHEN WE START THAT PROCESS WE
ANTICIPATE MORE INDIVIDUALS
WILL BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
RENEW. WE HAVE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MAKE THEM AWARE OF AND TRY
TO REDUCE THE BARRIERS AND
FINALLY WE ARE CONDUCTING AS
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE RECOMMENDED. AN
ASSESSMENT OF PROGRAM WHICH
WILL INCLUDE IDENTIFIED
BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION
AGENDA FIND ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUTRAGE AND
GENERAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE
COULD MAKE TO THE PROGRAM WE
ANTICIPATE HAVING RESULTS FROM
THAT STUDY WHICH IS BEING
CONDUCTED BY CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO. IN LATE
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY CONCERT
LATE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU- AND- HAVE
YOU SET GOALS THAT YOU WANT TO
SEE ACHIEVED THE- AS A RESULT
OF THE STEPS THAT YOU JUST
REFERRED TO. THIS IS JOHN
SELECTED STUDENT WORLD- WE ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUR PROGRAM THE TERMS
OF SPECIFIC GOAL SETTING. I
THINK WHEN THE ASSESSMENT
REPORT COMES OUT WILL BE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO HOPEFULLY
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC ACTIONS AND
GOALS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
ACTIONS. OKAY I THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE WHAT I'M
REFERRING TO IS- ACTUAL METRICS
THAT YOU WOULD- SEEK TO ACHIEVE
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING. YES WE ARE CHIRLA GREAT
GREAT OKAY THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. I'M SINGLE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY ASKING
ONE ADDITIONAL AND THAT IS- THE
STATE HAS BORROWED FROM THE
LIFELINE FUND IN IS REPAYING
THOSE FUNDS OVER THE NEXT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS- IS THAT LONG
GOING TO RESULT IN ANY
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACT. TO THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM. SUCH A
THOUGHT CREDITOR OUTSIDE IN
TAMPA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOW
THE STATE IS COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THERE'S NO IMPACT OF
LIFELINE PROGRAM INTO THAT AND
WOOD- BEGAN TO REPAY THIRTY
FIVE MILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR WITH THE REMAINING TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. GREAT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT- WILL
CLOSE OUT ISSUE NUMBER TWO WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AS TWO BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND SOME PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
BE DISCUSSED. WE HAVE- A
DRIBBLE HAND AND NATALIE LEE.
FROM THE- ENERGY COMMISSION
HERE TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS SO
MY COMING HERE OKAY. YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY WORKS CITED TO
BE THE IMPLEMENTOR OF THE
SCHOOL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STIMULUS PROGRAM ESTABLISHED BY
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE WHICH IS THE
FIRST ISSUE OR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS BEFORE YOU THIS
MORNING THIS BILL CREATES TO
PROGRAMS FOR SCHOOLS IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ONE
FOCUSES ON CLASSROOM
VENTILATION AND THE OTHER ON
INEFFICIENT PLUMBING FIXTURES
THE BILL IS INTENDED TO READ
I'LL BE BRIEF BUT I DO WANT TO
READ A QUOTE HERE IS INTENDED
TO QUOTE SAVE ENERGY. CREATE
JOBS AT A TIME OF ECONOMIC
CRISIS AND PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT TO SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
CHILDREN AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THAT'S A TALL
ORDER BUT WE'RE CONFIDENT WE
CAN DELIVER ON THOSE PROMISES.
AS OF TODAY I JUST WANT TO
BRING YOU UP TO SPEED ON WHERE
WE ARE WE DRAFTED AND PUBLISHED
PROGRAM GUIDELINES IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. WE HELD A
WORKSHOP AND HAVE RECEIVED
NUMEROUS COMMENTS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS BECOME A DEADLINE
WAS LAST FRIDAY. WE'RE
PREPARING RESPONSES TO THOSE
COMMENTS AND WILL SOON PUBLISH
UPDATED GUIDELINES BASED ON
THOSE COMMENTS AND THEN WILL
PRESENT OUR GUIDELINES
CONSISTENT WITH THE DIRECTIVE
OF THE STATUTE. TO OUR BOSSES
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION FOR
ADOPTION IN MAY. THE SENATE
AUTHORIZED UP TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM THIS MORNING WE
SEEK THREE POINT SIX FIVE
MILLION. SUPPORT TWENTY THREE
STAFF AND THAT FIGURE INCLUDES
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND WE ALSO
SEEK NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM A DIFFERENT FUND ARE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS FOR A
FRACTION OF P. Y. TO SUPPORT.
THOSE OF PORTION OF THE
LEGISLATION. L. CLOSE AARON
INVITE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. I'M
SAYING NONE- IS THERE A REPORT
FROM EITHER LMAO OR- FINANCE.
APPLE THE APPLE FINANCE. MISTER
CHARLES ROSS BROWN FROM THE LA-
O. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
ON THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
I'M NOT SURE IF NOW WOULD BE
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO MAKE
THOSE BUT I JUST WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT. GO RIGHT AHEAD.
OKAY SO- BUT AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THE-
REQUESTED BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM
THE COMMISSION. BECOMING
COMMENTS ON UP ON THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND AS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES THAT LANGUAGE WAS
RELEASED RELATIVELY RECENTLY SO
WE'RE STILL. LOOKING AT IT AND
WANT TO- YOU HAVE FURTHER
CONNOR NUMBER SIX INFLICTED
MINISTRATION. THANK WITH I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
PIECES OF IT ONE PIECE OF
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS.
OPERATING AN EXEMPTION FOR THE
EPIC PROGRAM FOR- SOME OF THE
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESSES THAT-
ENERGY COMMISSION IT USUALLY
HAS TO GO THROUGH FOR SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS- AND WE THINK.
THE EXEMPTION IN THIS CASE FOR
A KIND OF FOLLOW UP FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES
AND PROJECTS MAKE SENSE TO HELP
SPEED THAT. PROCESS ALONG AND
HELP SUPPORT THOSE PROJECTS- WE
DO THINK THE LETTERS THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER ADDING
SOME. ADDITIONAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE PERHAPS- A
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR EXAMPLE. TO ENSURE SOME-TRANSPARENCY AROUND WHEN THAT-
AUTHORITY IS EXERCISED SO
THAT'S ONE. ISSUE TO CONSIDER I
THINK THE OTHER ONE IS ON THE
TWO OTHER PIECES ARE.
REQUESTING CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY FOR
THE- NATURAL GAS FUNDING AS
WELL AS THE SCHOOL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM. FUNDING
AND- THAT- CAN REDUCE- AND
IMPAIR LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF
FUNDING- BY TAKING IT OUT OF
THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS AND
PROVIDING CAN YOU. CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS SO IN OUR VIEW
WE DO THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
VERY STRONG RATIONALE- TO
PROVIDE THAT CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY. AND AT
THIS TIME IT'S NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR THAT OUT OF FORTY IS
NEEDED TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THOSE PROGRAMS SO.
AGAIN AS YOU'RE JUST A NOTE
SAID- WE THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT
TO EXPLORE IN THE HEARING. AND
WE PLAN ON HAVING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS AND WILL UPDATE
THE COMMITTEE. AS WE EXPLORE
THE ISSUE FURTHER. THANK YOU-
SO- MISTER HAND- CAN YOU. THAT
IS REGARD. CONTINUOUS A PRO. OF
AVERSE- ANNUAL APPROPRIATION
AND THE- THE VALUE OF ONE OVER
THE OTHER DAY- AS YOU DO THAT
IF THERE IF YOU COULD PROVIDE.
OF A CONCRETE EXAMPLE OF HOW
THE ANNUAL APPROPRIATION
PROCESS. FOR EITHER OF THESE
REVENUE STREAMS. OF AS HAS IT
CAUSED A PROBLEM FOR THE
PROGRAM. ARE THERE ANY EXAMPLES
OF THAT. THANKS VERY MUCH- HERE
AGAIN THROUGH BONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- DRESS WITH YOUR
PERMISSION BOTH OF THE ISSUES-
THAT WAY- RAISED AND YOU YOU
REYES FIRST THE CONTINUOUS
PREPARATION AND THEN- ALL SPEAK
ABOUT THE CONTINUOUS- THE
FOLLOWING FUNDING. SO WITH
REGARD TO THE CONTENDERS
APPROPRIATION WE HAD A STROKE
AND A LOT OF FUNDING FOR CLEAN
ENERGY INVESTMENTS AND WE ARE
REALLY PROUD OF OUR STEWARDSHIP
OF THESE FUNDS. SOMETIMES
PROJECTS DON'T SPEND ALL THE
MONEY THAT WAS AWARDED AND WE
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING
BECAUSE- IT WHEN YOU FUND THE
PROJECT THERE ARE THERE'S A BIT
OF ESTIMATION THAT GOES ON AND
WE- A VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THE MANNER IN WHICH OUR
AWARDEES. SPEND THE FUNDS. AND
SOMETIMES THEY UNDERSTOOD. AND
WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING SO
WHEN THEY UNDERSTAND FUNDS
THOSE FUNDS REFER TO THAT THE
FUND ITSELF AND IN THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PURE
NATURAL GAS FUND. AND THEN WE
REQUIRED THROUGH THE P. YOU
SEE. TO SUBMIT A SUPPLEMENTAL
PLAN TO SPEND THOSE FUNDS AND
THAT WOULDN'T CHANGE UNDER OUR
PROPOSAL. HOWEVER ONCE APPROVED
BY THE P. YOU SEE THE LAW
REQUIRES TO COME BACK TO SEEK
PASSED THE CREDT REPORTING
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING TO GET THE CAN AS A
CORPORATION FOR. AND TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION CHAIR DIRECTLY.
UP YET TO CONCLUDE THAT DELAYS
SO FUNDS MAY FALL OUT- SOON
AFTER A BUDGET IS APPROVED THE
TIMING OF ANY GIVEN GRANT.
JERRY SAID SO WE'VE HAD THE
SITUATION WHERE FUNDS WILL FALL
OUT LET'S SAY IN JULY OF A
GIVEN YOUR JULY OR AUGUST. WE'D
LIKE PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES AND WANTED
TO GET FUNDS OUT INTO THE- INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
TURN AROUND AND VERY QUICKLY-
WE APPROPRIATE THE- LEAST WE
UNCOVER THOSE FUNDS THROUGH NEW
SOLICITATIONS. SO WITH THE
DELAY WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THE
NEXT BUDGET CYCLE COULD BE UP
TO UP TO A YEAR JUST SHY OF THE
YEAR AND THE EXAMPLE I GAVE AND
WE HAVE HAD THAT. HAPPEN JUST
GIVE ME A QUICK SENSE A CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
THE PAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE COME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. A
NUMBER OF TIMES IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE DID SO FOR THREE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS- FALL
YEAR FOR. JUST UNDER SIX
MILLION AND THEN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR EIGHT MILLION AND
SO- AGAIN IT WOULD JUST
PROVIDE- A SET UP SOME
FLEXIBILITY. THESE FUNDS HAVE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH AN
EXTENSIVE VETTING PROCESS
THROUGH THE- PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND WE PROVIDE
ANNUAL REPORTS. TO YOU ABOUT
HOW THOSE FUNDS WHICH THAT. I
DON'T STOP THERE BUT WOULD LIKE
TO THE CA. APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE. THE- STOLEN FROM IF
YOU WOULD WISH TO HEAR ABOUT
THE- THAT'S FIVE ONE TO GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT. OKAY WITH
RESPECT TO THAT LAST BUDGET
CYCLE WE WORK WE PROPOSED IN.
THE LEGISLATURE AGREED TO
PROVIDE THIS FALL ONE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY THIS WAS WITH
RESPECT TO OUR EPIC PROGRAM SO
I JUST WAS TALKING ABOUT
NATURAL GAS WHICH IS ALSO FROM
OUR RESEARCH DIVISION THESE ARE
ALL RESEARCH FUNDS. THIS IS
EPIC WHICH IS ELECTRICITY
FUNDS. NEARLY ALL THE FUNDING
THAT WE AWARD THROUGH AFFECT.
IS COMPETITIVELY BID AND WE AIM
TO KEEP IT THAT WAY. HOWEVER
OUR PROCESS IS THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE IT COULD TAKE A YEAR
OR SOMEONE WE CAN SEE THAT IDEA
AND WORKSHOPS ON A PARTICULAR
TOPIC TO THE AND PASSPORT
ULTIMATELY AWARDING THE FUNDS.
LAST YEAR THE BILL WAS SB. ONE
FIFTEEN IT GRANTED A SECURITY.
TO PROVIDE FOLLOWING FUNDING
FOR AMERICORPS PRICE BUT ONLY
UNDER REALLY. CONDITIONS I
WON'T GO THROUGH ALL THE JUST
TO RATTLE OFF QUICKLY- WE CAN
ONLY DO FOLLOW ON FUNDING THE
PRIME RECIPIENT IS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN 80% OR MORE OF
THE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE ORIGINAL
PROJECT HAD TO BE COMPETITIVELY
BID. UP THERE'S SOLID RESULTS
FROM THE PROJECT THERE'S-
BREAKTHROUGH POTENTIAL- WHAT
THE PARTIES HAVE TO BE SOME OF
THE NEAR TERM- PARTIES LIKE
WILDFIRES. AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
A JUDGMENT ABSENT FOLLOW ON
FUNDING A PROJECT THAT'S DOING
REALLY WELL MIGHT SCALE BECAUSE
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE
HIGH RISK AND THEY SOMETIMES
HAVE DIFFICULT DIFFICULTY
ATTRACTING- CAPITAL. TO THE
POINT ROSS ARE MADE FROM THE L.
A. O. THE SIXTY DAYS. WE THINK
THAT'S- WE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THAT APPROACH
BECAUSE AS WE SPEAK WE'VE GOT-
FIVE OR SIX OR SEVEN PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE CONTEMPLATING FOR
FOLLOW ON FUNDING FROM THE
AUTHORITY RECEIVED SOME MONTHS.
AGO IT TOOK US AWHILE TO.
PUTTING THE RULES OF TAKE AND
UP WITH PROCESS QUICK SOME THAT
ARE TO GO. A COUPLE OF THEM
COULD BE IN PLACE BY SUMMER AND
ARE DIRECTED TOWARD HELPING
RELIEVE ARE- CHALLENGES WE'VE
HAD ON THE GRITS OF THE
TIGHTENING. THAT IT COULD BE
VERY VERYGOOD AND IF WE ADD
THE SIXTY DAY. THE SECURITIES
AND IT COULD JUST PROVIDED THE
LACK. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER- ASK OUR STAFF TO TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AS WE
CONTINUE OUR EVALUATION OF- OF
THESE OF BUDGET REQUESTS. AGAIN
WE'RE TAKING NO ACTION TODAY
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT- THAT AND
I THINK- WILL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND TO. OF
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT CONCLUDES THE OF
PRESENTATIONS FOR- TODAY'S
HEARING- IS THERE ANYONE. WHO
IS HERE IN THE- IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT
AND- SEEING NO HANDS GO UP- I'M
GOING TO REPEAT THE OF TOLL
FREE NUMBER THAT YOU CAN CALL.
IF YOU WANNA CALL. RIGHT NOW
AND TO DELIVER PUBLIC COMMENTS
OF ONE MINUTE APIECE THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
1-757-877-6928 NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN IF YOU
EXPERIENCE ANY DIFFICULTIES YOU
CAN CALL THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE- AGAIN YOU
CAN SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS. AT
THE EMAIL ADDRESS. BUDGET SUB
THREE THAT'S B. U. D. G. E. T.
S. U. B. NUMERAL THREE. AT A.
S. M. DOT CA DOT GOV. OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE- ANYONE WAITING TO
GET PUBLIC COMMENTS. THANK YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO. EXPRESS
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU SHOULD
HEAR A TONE IN A CAGE IN THE
YOU'VE BEEN PLACED IN QUEUE
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO
HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q. ARE YOU
READY FOR THE FIRST. I AM
PLEASE PROCEED. YEAH WE'LL GO
TO LINETWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SPEAKERONLINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SPEAKER ONLINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. COME BACK TO THAT ONE
UP THAT'S OKAY OF COURSE. WHAT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JADE AND MAY NIELSEN
READERSHIP COUNCIL PROJECT THE
PHOENICIAN ABILITY- WE WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES. AND RURAL
INLAND CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE
TECH COUNTY TO MAKE THAT
COUNTY- I WANTED TO REINFORCE
HER SUPPORT FOR INCREASED
INVESTMENT EXPANDED REGULATORY
TOOL INTERNET EVERYWHERE AND
EVERY CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS
OR LIVE ON A PORTABLE INTERNET
ACCESS THE QUESTIONING THAT LED
THEM TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE- MY PENSION FOR
EXPERIENCING- BROADBAND ACCESS
ISSUES. I'M COMMITTED BY STATE
MAGNIFIED THAT INTERNET ACCESS
IS A NECESSITY AND SHOULD BE
TREATED AS SUCH MOST PUBLIC
CULTURE- BACKING RENTAL YOU
TYPICALLY SHOW THESE RELIEF
RESOURCES INFORMATION ARE BEING
SHARED THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA AND
ONLINE AND IS NOT REACHING
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT MOST-
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO FULLY
CONNECTED ENGAGE IN THE-
CLASSROOM. I THINK THE CLINTONS
ARE DONE ON. AND MAKE UP FOR
THOSE WITHOUT DEVICE THERE IN A
ORANGE LITTER AND EXPERIENCE OF
TECHNOLOGY I'M ONE OF THE KEY
MEMBERS TO WORK WHICH IS ABOUT
THE ORDEAL I'M A LEADER IN WHEN
THEY'RE RECENTLY SPOKEN CAN BE
PR ON THE BARRIER CARE. INDIANS
TO BE ON THE AGAINST NINETEEN
TO- TECHNO. TECHNOLOGICAL
KERRIER. I'M ON TOP OF THAT
LINE MARKET AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WERE PRIORITIZE FOR
BACKING BUT WE CAN NOT PUT INTO
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND THE
MAIN BARRIER IN LIMITED
INFORMATION THAT INTERNET
ACCESS AND BROADBAND- FINALLY
AT LEVEL. ONE THAT LETS
RESIDENTS TO BE FOR THE CLEAN
GAUGED ASK QUESTIONS TO WITH
THEIR CONCERN BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T ACCESS. THE CLIENT EMAIL
LIVE STREAM- IT REALLY LIMITS
THE CONNECTION TO THE
COMMUNITY- UNLESS YOU ARE
ACTUALLY ORGANIZATION ORGANIZER
AND THERE'S A DIRECT CONNECTION
THE COMMUNITY- TO SOMEONE WHO
CAN- NAVIGATE THE ONLINE SYSTEM
AND-
THE PUBLIC PROCESS. I
THINK THE ISSUE AN EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE- THE PROGRAM.
NOT EXPAND NATURAL GAS
RESOURCES INCLUDING BIOMETHANE-
THAT IS NEITHER CLEAN NOR
RENEWABLE AND PERPETUATE BOTH
LOCAL AND REGIONAL POLLUTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
WELL WE HAVE ANOTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT. COMES FROM LINE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JEFF NEAL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES- OUR
MEMBERS OF COURSE ESPECIALLY
OUR OUR RULED SUPERVISORS HAVE
BEEN TALKING FOR YEARS ABOUT
UNEVEN ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND
THE EVENTS OF THIS LAST YEAR
HAVE JUST HIGHLIGHTED THE-
INEQUITIES- BETWEEN THOSE WHO
HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND
THOSE WHO DON'T AND SO. THAT
YOU'RE MORE THAN EVER WE THINK
THE EXPANDING BROADBAND ACCESS
IS NOT ONLY UNNECESSARY PIECE
OF ANY ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN I
GO TALK TO A MORAL IMPERATIVE.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
STREAMING NETFLIX WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIANS MAKE
APPOINTMENTS TO SEE KOBE BANKS
BEING SENT AND TALK TO THEIR
DOCTOR AND RIGHT NOW THE SEE
HOW CHILDREN ATTEND SCHOOL AND
DO HOMEWORK- INDEED EXISTED
BEFORE THEY JUST BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED THIS YEAR. IN
EQUITY YOU KNOW FALL MOST
HEAVILY ON THE SAME COMMUNITY
THAT THAT ARE ALREADY I HAVE
INEQUITABLE ACCESS TO EDUCATION
AND TECHNOLOGY AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. AND I THINK IT
TAKING BIRD THOSE OF US WITH
BROADBAND TO FORGET BOOK OF
JUST HOW MUCH OF OUR LIVES I
TAKE PLACE ONLINE SO. I THINK
THEY'RE KEEPING THAT THE STATE-
AND COUNTY ARE WORKING TOGETHER
CAN DO ABOUT IT ONE IS THAT THE
FACT IS URGING THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED MINISTRATION TO
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT THE
BROADBAND CALL ACTION PLAN THAT
WAS ADOPTED BY THE BROADBAND
COUNCIL IN DECEMBER WE ENDORSE
IT. IN ITS ENTIRETY AND WE
THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL CASES
OF IT IF THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED
IMMEDIATELY THEY CAN HELP ANY
MONEY THAT THAT COMES TO
WHETHER IT'S THE TSF PROGRAM
THE COMMISSION OF THE MINUTES
OF ITS WITH TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER DID YOU FEDERAL MONEY
TO COME DOWN BUT THERE CAN YOU
NEW STATE MONEY TO HOPE THAT HE
WOULD BE STAFF MONEY MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
FORGET SOME OF THOSE THINGS
GOING. QUICKLY THE OTHER THING
THAT WE WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO- EVEN AS PART
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS HUNDRED
XCELERATED TIMELINE IS THE
PASSAGE OF EIGHTY FORTUNATE SB
FOUR- I KNOW THEY'RE NOT. IT BY.
NAME BEFORE YOU TODAY BUT THEY
WOULDN'T MAKE MANY OF THE ROUGH.
IS BECAUSE WITH ME MANY. TE
SAME OF THAT OKAY MINNESOTA ITS
WITH. I DISCUSSING ACTING. IT
WOULD ALL THE ONE BILLION BRIBE
BOND THAT COULD JUMP- IT.
BUILDS WITH ALL OF THAT.
BENEFITS COME ALONG WITH THAT.
SO WE WOULD. I'M ENCOURAGING
YOU TO CONSIDER IMPLEMENT THE
BROAD POLITICS PLAN PASSING
THOSE BILLS ON. TIMELINE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO THE YOU.
IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS SEEMING A PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. TO
HAVE A FEW MORE PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. WELL NEXT TO LINE UP
TWENTY ONE TO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VERONICA AVAILABLE TO CREATE
THAT CHRISTIANITY'S I'M CALLING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FLORIDA CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
SUMMIT. WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE STAFF ANALYSIS BEFORE YOU
AND WANT TO STRONGLY RECOMMEND
AS STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION CONFUSE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND THE JUMPSTART
BROADBAND INVESTMENT. AND
REALLY WORK TOWARDS ADDRESSING
THE SEVEN BILLION IN NEED AT
YOUR FACTORED IN THIS DAY
ACTION PLAN. ADDITIONALLY WE
URGE QUICK QUICK ACTION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE SEVERE AND EQUITIES THE
PANDEMIC AS- EXPOSED ACROSS OUR
STATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
FINAL COMMENT IN Q. WAS LYING
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO THE LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS PAMELA LOPEZ
WITH KEITH STREET CONSULTING ON
BEHALF OF TRUE CONNECT A
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROVIDER.
WE ECHO THE CONCERNS OF CARE
PERSON BLOOM WITH REGARD TO OUR
OVERALL LIFELINE PARTICIPATION
RATE THINKING COULD BE COPYING
OR WHETHER IN THE WAY- IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN LIGHT OF
THE- STATE PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS BEING FACED BY
SO MANY FAMILIES. THAT OVERALL
NEED AND DEMAND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM
WOULD BE WOULD BE DOWN AND YET
THE LIFELINE B. C. P. DATA IN
THE LIFELINE BCPS SUBMITTED BY
THE CPUC SHOWS THAT PEOPLE ARE
DROPPING OFF THE PROGRAM AT THE
AVERAGE. CHURN RATE THAT
THEY'VE ALWAYS DROPPED OFF BUT
THAT YOU CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT
FINDING NOT- WE ALSO SUBMITTED
DATA TO A CHAIR PERSON BLOOM
AND ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WHICH SHOWED BACK UP
ROUGHLY ABOUT 10215% OF.
INDIVIDUALS IN EACH OF THE
DISTRICTS OF EACH OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE. THAT
ACTUALLY QUALIFY FOR THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM ARE IN BOLD AT
BROADBAND AND CONNECTIVITY ARE
AN IMPORTANT. PART OF MAKING
SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR PHONE AND
INTERNET UT ACTUALLY MAKING
SURE THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A PHONE IN
THEIR HAND AND THAT THAT PHONE
HAS ACCESS TO DATA. THAT THEY
CAN USE IS ANOTHER CRITICAL
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE WE WOULD
ALSO SUGGEST THAT IN PREVIOUS
YEARS LIFELINE PROVIDERS HAD
DONE A GOOD JOB OF OUR
INVOLVEMENT AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS AT THAT THE WAY THAT-
REIMBURSEMENT HOT STOCKCHARTS
THE LIFELINE PROVIDER HAVE BEEN
ALTERED IN RECENT YEARS. HAS
CREATED DISINCENTIVES FOR
LIFELINE PROVIDERS THEMSELVES
TO CONTINUE DOING THAT WORK AND
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT LIKE
FIND INVOLVEMENT IS DOWN. WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER THE- SURPLUS THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY. BE AVAILABLE
IN THE EARMARKED FOR BY BUDGET
AFTER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR LOAN REPAID. TO LOOK AT
OPTIONS FOR. LIFELINE PER. IN
REVENGE. AND REDOING THEIR AT
UP AFTER IT. IT'S NICE TO WAIT
FOR A STUDY FROM- STOCKS. I
COULD COME IN I AT THE VERY END
THIS YEAR BUT A WHOLE YEAR GONE
BY ISSUE TO WAIT TO. THAT BUT
THE FACT WE'RE NOT AND I SIX.
RIGHT NOW. AND WORKING WITH. TO
GET THOSE AFFECT UP AND RUNNING
AGAIN IS THE QUICKEST AND- MOST
MOST PROVEN BECAUSE IT'S WORKED
IN THE PASSED- WAY TICKET TECH
AT- INVOLVEMENT FOR LIKE MINE
UP AND RUNNING AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS. NO
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM THE
PHONES. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR THAT BRINGS US TO
THE CONCLUSION OF OUR HEARING
AND TO A- LESSER IS ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. WE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU ALL. WHAT
SOMETHING ABOUT TRUMP.